I'm a conservative I identify as a
liberal I will be handcuffed to a
liberal for 24 hours how's it going hi
I'm that Brandon hi Brandon nice to meet
you a lot of people think Planned
Parenthood is only about abortions I've
gotten a lot of my sexual education from
Planned Parenthood there's still gonna
be free clinics all over the country
nothing's gonna change with that as far
as PC culture goes I think people need
to toughen up a little bit more I think
people are way too sensitive right now
and I think people just need to sack up
a little bit more just because it
doesn't relate to you or just because
you don't see it as they oh this is huge
doesn't mean that it's not huge to
someone else I'm right-handed are you
right-handed yeah hello are we gonna get
to know each other my breath no your
thank you I think I feel more nervous
than I worry I think I'm ready for it
just going and that makes me even more
afraid what do you think that was an
honest reaction probably to the election
first we wanted to get to know each
other and I think that played a big role
in understanding why our views are so
strong okay here's another one let's
let's look at this one here
it is our responsibility
Trump is Maxine Obama was getting we the
people we make this country all right so
we're gonna get non-dairy milk because I
feel like being nice to this girl to
tank up yeah
lady came out and was just like shocked
sick what is going on why are you doing
this and then another guy walked by he
just stopped me is like I'm not even
gonna ask and I just kept walking so
Brandon and I are gonna be cooking
dinner tonight we're going to be having
some chicken and some mashed potatoes I
don't know how we did it but we did it
it took us two hours well it took about
two hours to cook some chicken first
class of the night okay so are you what
do you want to do I'll do the chicken do
mexicanos or switch I've really done
community you were distracted by our
conversation we were distracted by
handcuffs don't we talk about the death
penalty abortion abortion we talked
about gun laws where one of them was BLM
and I think on that one we kind of agree
but then there's certain things there's
certain questions that each of us had I
think for each other I get every year
and everyone else but yeah well I mean I
think it's been coming that their life
you matter I don't think
tell America I think everyone was but I
think that America has shown it time and
time again so you know I think because
we were attached to each other we
probably took the time to try to
understand each other more likely to
feel we didn't really start screaming at
each other yelling at each other
anything we just had questions for each
other I grew up in not the best
neighborhoods my mom tried to do good
for me but I kind of would go off on my
own thing and hang out with my friends
and do shady [ __ ] right in front of so
anyways yes I have been in the juvenile
detention program my entire teenage
years pretty much but do you know that
even with all of that that you have done
if you were to filled out a job
application or apply ourselves to
college even with your background
records and mine being completely clean
yours would probably be accepted before
money probably what you suggest because
you're white when conversations do get
heavy like that it's so easy to get
frustrated and leave and assume that you
don't want to put up with it I don't
think so you think you just go into a
job and people like the guy to interview
it but a guy I interview it it's just
like okay you're like cool check you're
good
but I would think if there was ever an
opportunity where the two were side by
side there had to be an option to pick
between the two definitely will change
depending on who the employer is but you
would have to advance what about Obama I
mean that's run that's the one exception
Bank parsing there's so many people that
are in high positions that are IQ to
uses for some color I think it really
forced us to like for one not get upset
because if you get upset you didn't go
anywhere but she just be like okay and
like ask questions I was starving by
that time I think I inhaled my food he
was a little more polite and took his
time you know I don't play so I just had
some amazing dinner with someone now we
have to try to uh wash dishes handcuffed
bedtime it's bedtime I told him that I
have to write my hair so oh god take the
watch off with this possible yes
sleeping sucked showering obviously
sucks yeah yes I was slightly surprised
I thought I was gonna go into this and
be handcuffed to some like super hippie
and I was pleasantly surprised she's
awesome and we got along just great just
because you are conservative does not
mean you know that you are uptight and
you hate everyone who's not like you and
we are cool now like we're good we
exchanged numbers we're probably going
to hang out after this I think it was
good
to show like my friends conservative or
liberal that we can coexist I think it's
important during these times in America
to show that that we can get along I
think that an experience like this is
going to help me understand other people
and their ideas if we could kind of
think of ourselves as attached to each
other
maybe we would try to maneuver and help
each other move through life I mean I
found that since we were literally found
together we weren't in it for ourselves
we
we're moving with one another to make
sure that the person could do what they
needed to do then another guy pass and
he was like oh that's dope
like I like that I think you gonna go
more like hey I saw you I hope we gotta
try it